in 1949 Mao Zedong proclaimed the
creation of the People's Republic of
China whilst he was doing this the
Chinese civil war was still raging on
with the Kuomintang opposition fleeing
to the island of Taiwan and by 1951 all
of mainland China in the island of
Hainan was under the control of the
Chinese Communist Party which raises the
obvious question why didn't Malkin Kurt
I wan what the first reason was that Mao
still needed to consolidate the
Communist Party's hold on mainland China
now the Communist armed forces the
People's Liberation Army was about three
times the size of the kawaman tank
military but numbers aren't everything
the PLA had a miniscule Air Force
whereas the Kuomintang had a modern one
made up of mostly American fighters and
bombers also the PLA didn't have a Navy
whereas the overwhelming majority of
China's old ships had been taken to
Taiwan Mao stationed troops along the
coastline and prepared for an invasion
of the remaining Kuomintang positions
the closest of which were the CREM
Islands when the go-ahead was given the
invasion was to put it mildly a disaster
this setback wasn't enough to deter
mouth' oh and he ordered plans for the
final conquest of Taiwan to be drafted
the plan was to buy as many
transportation vessels as possible and
simply overwhelm the island with sheer
numbers this plan was scrapped because
frankly it was a stupid one and also Mao
was concerned that the USA would
intervene if he invaded which he was
right about because the United States
placed his fleet between China and
Taiwan and made it clear to Mao that any
invasion would also mean war with them
however by this point Mao had another
issue to deal with since the Korean War
had just begun next door they so direct
fighting between Chinese and American
forces and importantly so US President
Harry Truman commits to defend non
communist regimes in the area including
Chiang kai-shek's Kuomintang government
in Taiwan in 1953 a ceasefire ended the
fighting on the Korean Peninsula and so
mauka turned his attention back to
Taiwan and boy did he because the next
year he ordered the shelling of the
kwame Islands to which the Taiwanese
government responded tit for tat things
began to escalate and President Truman
did three things first of all he sent
reinforcements to Taiwan second-team
Congress passed legislation committing
the us to defend Taiwan in the event of
invasion and third he threatened to nuke
China this worked and Mao somewhat
opposed to being nuked ordered his
forces to desist and this threat
convinced Mao of one thing that China
needed its own nuclear weapons if it was
ever going to stand up to the United
States or ever hope to assert itself
over Taiwan however before these nuclear
weapon
were finished my award at the shelling
of the islands again because at this
point why not it was something to do I
guess this time the air forces got
involved in hundreds of people died in
president eisenhower threatened to
invade the mainland if things didn't
calm down which they promptly did now
this was the last time that China
attempted to forcibly capture territory
from Chiang kai-shek where Mao died in
1976 his successor preferred a policy of
peaceful reunification in the end Mao
didn't conquer Taiwan for one very
simple reason he couldn't the US Navy
sat between China and Taiwan and it was
by far the most powerful in the world
and where Mao tried to use force and
nuclear retaliation by the United States
was an ever-present threat not to
mention that any attempt by Mao to take
the island would have been costly in
lives and money which given the fact he
was trying to build a Revolutionary
Government was something that he needed
more than Taiwan I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching but
thanks to my patreon supporters whom you
can see on screen now and with an extra
special thanks to James Bissonnette Ike
Danny Maloney calling Castleman Marvin
Castle Rob Waterhouse Aaron the white
Jordan long way Chris wicker Gustav
Swann Gareth Turner
Marcus Ozma Maggie packs Kowski David
Silverman spinning three plates
Spencer Lightfoot Lexi Schwinn Winston
Cawood Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett the original cage Robert
Wetzel Skye Chappell par shoe 19 and Moe